[Applause]
it's so good to see
you I love you so much you so much no
it's like I'm like having to control
myself yeah no like I took beta blockers
so I don't start crying I oh well you
can always cry here and I've heard yes
yes this is where we can just live a
life and like can I pet your dog is that
okay I really should can you pet here
Douglas come on
up um I know isn't it's just so healing
is it true that you have three cats yes
I have three cats and two dogs yeah yeah
yeah I have four cats and oh yes yes I
really love the animals they make me
feel calm and joyful I mean they're
everything I I honestly I was crying
yesterday morning to my husband talking
about one of my cats who I miss so much
and I was like she her face is just love
and I see like my grandmother when I
look in her like the love that I felt
with her you know I mean oh my God guys
good
luck no no no this animal I actually I
made a documentary called pets that's
going to be coming out this year and I
love your other documentaries I mean
you're an amazing like filmmaker you're
an amazing filmmaker
you're
amazing storytelling is awesome and it's
powerful and the industry is getting
stronger and stronger by the day and
more and more inclusive by the day and
you really you represent that in so many
ways Drew I mean there was there was
this one time that I saw you like I'm a
very enthusiastic person I'm a very
emotional person I know I know I saw you
once when you were doing Charlie's
Angels and you were walking in and you
had blonde hair and you were like this
big and there were all these men around
you who this big in suits and you were
like guys I am so excited for the
screening this is going to be
amazing and it was like you you were
just the you represented female power
and to see female power have such
lightness and joy and enthusiasm and and
just you were bringing everyone in into
that energy and I was like oh my God I
don't have to play it cool ever I don't
ever have cuz I can't I can't either I
can't I just thank you you know thank
you for just being so yourself and you
know you know and always from day one so
anyway the compliment comes back also to
your family when we started producing
for flower films when I was 19 Nan and I
always talked about you know your dad
and Brian graser and what they had
created with imagine the film company
that told some of in my humble opinion
and I'm not the only one the most
important stories that we have in
cinema whether it be you know a splash
or maybe the film that might represent
human beings like if the if the aliens
came down and they said what are human
beings I would be like watch Parenthood
oh my gosh that's that's who we are
that's what we are and who we are at our
truest it's it's a masterpiece oh my
gosh thank you it's totally based on my
family like way too much is it true that
you're also in it that you did a part in
it yeah when I was years old I got to be
an extra in Parenthood and it was like
the first the first thing that I ever
got to do and it was amazing it was it
was incredible and it was what was
really funny was like the fact that my
dad chose the first time that I was
getting to be an extra it was like a
night shoot for three nights okay by the
way how do you think that you and your
dad have come to conclusions or lived a
life true to being yourself I grew up
very very very very very sheltered and
protected and it's really my mom my my
mom and my dad have been together since
they were 16 Cheryl yes and she is she's
a force of nature she she she soloed her
first plane when she was 16 when she
there wasn't a sport for girls in her
school she cut off all her hair and told
everyone her name was Charlie and she
played football and then when they found
out she started a track team like she's
like a very very very tough distinctive
singular lady like she's a writer she
writes esoteric science fiction she's
just so unapologetically herself and I
think that that like she in a way raised
my dad to be that way cuz they've been
together since they were 16 and she's
just kept him so honest and real and I
mean let's face it your dad also Opie
Happy Days you know your dad grew up in
the business how did your parents meet
high
school high school John Bros High School
but you know while they had an
incredible relationship in high school
and everything he proposed three times
and she said no to of them because she
was like I want to go to school first I
don't want to like I'm not ready you
know to be on your train yet sound so
strong she's really strong I was
thinking because you've been in all
these extraordinary movies um and I
can't wait to talk about our and at the
center of our gu Is This Love Story and
I I hope that's not a spoiler alert
because I'm almost afraid to talk about
the movie because there is so many
unexpected twists and turns in this film
and the chemistry between you I told Sam
I'm like we've been friends for three
decades so close three movies together
I'm like this is I think your sexiest
you've ever been oh my God absolutely
he's so hot in it he's so hot in it he's
so hot in it and and there's this whole
like whole thing where I play a spy
novelist and I'm writing about this this
a kind of idealized version of a spy
played by Henry caval But but so Sam
plays like the real spy but
then Sam Rockwell let's just say guys
everyone be prepared but you guys have
like the best chemistry you are just
going to be so delighted with this film
although you've been in so many
extraordinary things and your tapestry
of work is so beautiful can we celebrate
it really quickly with a behind the
scenes sure
[Music]
[Applause]